all right welcome to another hang out /
blab super excited to be here with i
want to say mark in the car mark out of
the car bug Draeger from phantom media
has an awesome series called mark in the
car that's coming back at some point
good Jerry soon and we're going to LA
we're going some questions so what does
he watch him live you can do / q and ask
question but we got some lined up
question I'm going to go through and
here we go so first one came in Zen is a
nap zainab Abdullah do you have videos
up about how to start selling ones
product to neighboring cities also would
it be advisable to employ worthy
candidates to become agents of the
products especially different cities so
someone you're planning to you uh
neighboring city I don't know what
they're selling but how do you sell to
any greasy that's an interesting
questions so I mean if you can sell by
buy online or by phone the way I would
think about it is if you're generating
leads in these other cities so if you
already have people calling you from
these other cities and you can do that
not locally if you that my phone or
online or go to meeting or what have you
then you just sell your products and
then when it comes time to deliver
either ship it out there and get the
crew out there or just basically deliver
the product in that area I mean we have
clients who are all you know across
America in the US and when the pricing
allows me just send the right people out
or hire the right local crew deliver on
that or was selling by phone that's it
leads are coming in if leads aren't
coming in from those other cities then I
would say you need either an online
presence in those cities landing page
strategy around those cities or keyword
strategy or you really need to consider
yes getting some reps in those cities so
we have a client as a manufacturer who
wants to move into in country they've
lined up a whole bunch of reps who are
gonna we're gonna sell for them and then
they get a connection of each sale uh I
would try to let your customers take you
to the markets so as an example in my
first software company we had customers
in 30 countries and we couldn't we
couldn't rep all those countries most
because of cultural differences language
differences time zone differences so we
handled the North American market and
then I I sold off distribution
to different markets so if we got leads
coming in from Japan we have a local
Japanese partner who could work with
them talk to them to meet them and so
I'd be looking at are you getting
interest from other cities are people
willing to drive across the border to
come to your store you know if not then
maybe you're not doing a good enough job
in your local market yet to build up
awareness I think about China that's
also where we are now and we started in
North York and our customers took us
downtown and our customers at some
points taking us to other markets as
well people who are driving in from
three hours out of town to come to a
salsa class and maybe it's worth looking
at opening up closer to them and then
have an instructive go out so I'd be I'd
be definitely looking at where your
customers cause you from and then plot
in your strategy know how to grow in
that local market if you have enough
enough people who are interested yeah
super tempting to to try and think you
know what I have a business of exercise
in this city if I go all to all these
other cities I can have a multiple of
that business size just by being in
those cities and operating and I thought
that number of years ago you know in
Canada it's a very large country and so
I thought why I can be here in Toronto
and I give me Montreal which is five
hours away by car I can be in Calgary
which is like a five hour flight away
and I could grow my business just by
being in more areas and then and then
this guy here pointed out to me that we
hadn't yet hit like market cap we hadn't
yet actually sold every possible person
in our area and so while I'm busy taking
on risk and focusing on all these other
little cities and all those other things
you want ignoring a whole bunch of
business right here on my on my back
door and and so the way I always think
about now is I'm doing everything I can
do in my city I mean everything I can do
and I have really outgrown my geography
then you start looking at other places
if you're leaving stuff on the table in
your own city and taking on the risk of
looking at other ones I don't know it
seems like the easy way out now but it's
taking on a lot of risk cope next up
Eugene wrote this crazy email like the
wall of text Eugene sat down but it's
all about you because it sent out an
email tool marks business awesome let me
skip down to
at the end basically after reading the
email you just sent by Google's transit
media and I saw and I saw the amazing
work those guys put in and really
inspired me I too want to be
extraordinary do you have any
suggestions how can he be extraordinary
he does create a media found their
freedom media okay so if you can I cover
this on the channel we did so if you
think video is coming to the channel
about this but i would say i would say
one word aside if your words
extraordinary like mine or whatever it
is is put that aside in our type of
industry it all comes down to the people
your abilities right when you're when
you're manufacturing you got to put out
widgets and if you buy a piece of
machinery you get things whatever and
you start putting out the widgets and
it's widget after we shut the widget i
was just talking with one of our
producers oscar a few minutes ago about
the fact that in our business every
projects different every client is
different every day you can make or
break your name right your reputation is
really what you have and so when my
business went you know the last close to
ten years where went from just me alone
doing pretty bad work doing mediocre
work to us producing the portfolio that
you see in our site now and the work we
do the future comes down to the team and
the people and hiring the right people
and all of that stuff for my one word
but i appreciate when people compliment
the company on the work we do and a lot
of times they say you know you are so
good at the work and I have to stop them
in remind them that it's not me i have
this is amazing team of creative smart
people behind me and it's the same no
matter your industry if you're an
accounting firm if you're a lawyer if
you're in a creative industry the only
thing that makes you different from
everyone else is the work that you do
and how you go about it and that is only
done by the people that you have yeah I
so to add to that I would say you know
the quality of the work that you put is
super important even just looking at you
right why did I write about Mark in the
first place because he had a company
that I thought was worth writing about
he had a good story right so like do you
have a good story for your business and
a passion for what you're doing and then
you googled his company and went to his
website is like wow this work
is really good so if I went to your
website you're in creative media I went
to your site and looked at whatever
you're making am I going to get Wow and
that will help you get business right
like if people come to your site and
they see what you're creating well I
want that or something like that or
these are the best guys then you're
going to get these businesses referrals
coming to you and so if you want to be
extraordinary them again every decision
that you make should be to those lens
right you know am I an extraordinary
leader dr extraordinary team is my
product extraordinary is my routine in
the morning extraordinary is the balance
that I eat extraordinary like every day
everything right it's important hey you
wanna you want to be extraordinary
eating extraordinary breakfast what's
your breakfast coffee copies in the glen
eira breakfast coffee a lot a lot of
black coffee you need an extraordinary
breakfast so everything that you do
should be through that lens and that
will help you become a story to the
point where if somebody sees your stuff
they want to learn more about you they
want to start a few news there they want
to ask you questions just like you are
doing from mark but but don't stop you
know like I i super love it when people
compliment us obviously i love it when
they like the work we're doing but our
portfolio is is like on a russian that
it's apropos like 12 months old on our
website and last summer Evan looked at
our stuff he was just likes not good
enough right so I love that people think
that you are watching or whatever email
us think that our work is good enough
but he's then coming to me and
challenging saying get better get
stronger keep pushing dr reinvent who
you guys are can you do it faster can
you have more heart can you have more
feeling can you push the status quo and
so like the last 3-4 months we have were
coming on board that's that's that's
living that again in my mind and I'm
like yes we're doing it guys we're doing
in team we're pushing ourselves this is
awesome there's energy there's feeling
it feels like a start up again after
almost ten years in business it feels
like a start-up and then I'm going to
show it to Evan méxico like not good
enough keep going keep going so have
those people in your life as well those
in your life who aren't just gonna pat
you on the back and say wow you've made
it coast relax you know you don't want
those people who are putting you down
but you want those people who are gonna
you know with love and
respect challenge you to keep getting
better who believe you can get better
yeah okay Marquis uh again response to
your message so how can someone such as
myself do this if I if I have nothing
I'm hard I'm determined I've never I
never give up anything but I'm only 19
no home no car how can I reach my goals
mm-hmm one clearly defined what your
goals are write them down one goal two
goals 3 goals you know it's funny this
morning I was looking for something on
my laptop and I went back to notes i had
to my very first year in business and I
was actually reviewing my goals they
were like close to a decade old and you
know when I started my business my first
year i made like eighteen thousand
dollars and i had a wife at home with no
income i had my daughter was like three
months old and you might say wow you
made a lot of money but like we were we
were like not on food stamps but you
were really really poor and it was so
hard for that year and i looked at the
goals my one goal was like my dream was
to get a minivan so that way my wife
would have a safe vehicle to drive my
daughter around all right now I look
back and I'm just like wow that seems
simple that seems every day but when you
have nothing one like right that goal
down and work on that goal and if your
goal is to have a camera work on it work
on getting the camera and then work on
the lenses and then you know if you're
in a creative industry if you're if
you're in another industry you know the
people I respect the most the people who
have made it but of the most humble and
grounded or the people who come from
nothing or the people who have had a
hard time you know you spend two hours
on a bus getting to where you need to be
every day with your kid that's gonna pay
off and and so if you're 19 I started my
company when I was 23 23 or 24 you know
I've no smarter than anyone else I'm no
harder working than anyone else I
certainly want to sort do better work
than anyone else and but but it's just
you have your goal you work towards that
couple to one day and and then you're
gonna look back and go really that was
my goal that seems so simple that seems
so but you're gonna pull yourself out of
it so it
doesn't matter if you don't have the
connections or if you don't have the
family or the money or what have you
you're just going to work maybe take a
little bit longer but it's going to be
so sweet it's going to be so satisfying
when that pays off and you get to where
you want to be I would add to that I
think you got to adjust your mindset and
that there's a lot of things in your
email that we said uh you know i'm 19
i'm too young I don't have a car I don't
have a home and having these things as
being limiting beliefs that because
you're too young you can't have success
is something to help me back when I was
getting started when I was 19 and my
first software company feeling like how
am I gonna convince guys three times my
age with PhDs to buy for me when I don't
know anything about science i'm trying
to sell scientific software and that
helped me back for a while I realized
that they don't care how old I am did
you scare that I can add value and I
could and that switch made a huge
difference to me um I still don't have a
car or so or cell phone or or so you
know don't leave I hold you back man
proper shoes listen I have proper shoes
the shoes are awesome he just doesn't
like my five toe shoes um yeah so don't
don't I mean we all have these stories
that we tell ourselves is the why we
can't be successful it's not about your
education at some of that hold you are
sound of the car you drive it's just can
you provide value to people and that's
what I would focus on gaining the
experience we provide value people can I
share a story so you know when when we
whenever we make little tweaks in our
business or weren't a video business or
video production company whenever we
stepped outside of it the world of video
people would actually say to me to be
like who who are you to do this you're
in a video business who are you to say
that you're that you are capable of
strategy who are you to say that you're
capable of developing reputation
management campaign who are you say
whatever it is and people would say
that's my face I'd be like you know I
don't fulfilling me out or whatnot and I
would just share my story I I can't
answer your question Who am I to say it
all I know is I'm saying this to you I'm
trying to I'm trying to help you out
this is this is the experience i have
this is what I'm capable of doing and
you can
side with you want to work with us or
not and so when you're 19 you know you
don't have a lot of those things you may
not have the confidence yet but you
don't have to have everything figured
out you know you have so much you know
let's say you spend 10 years getting
experience you're gonna be 29 let's say
you spend another 10 years really
perfecting yourself you're gonna be 39
by the time you're 65 or 70 and retiring
even if you like if you were really
really great at 39 so another 25 years
you'll have a 25-year career of being at
the top of your game and being awesome
at so that's like full life's career
right there I've already being awesome
and that took you 20 years to get there
you have so much time so work on it work
on it work but but not like I don't know
if I think the pressures off the right
thing but just give yourself at the time
you need because you're going to get
better as you go cool okay next up
venkatesh thank you for sharing mark
story currently or it's a good story on
the missile you'll be able to see mark
story ah her language some official
speaking leadership training could you
please help me on successful marketing
company market himself as a motivational
speaker and inertia trini best way to
mark yourself you know everything's
probably the person to ask because evan
is like the captain of this but i would
say one define again to find the value
that you bring understand who you bring
that value to so so understand what
you're speaking to and the value bring
will people pay for that value is that
something they would actually pay for in
our business we have lots of high-value
services we could offer but and everyone
agrees or high value but no one's
willing to expose budget behind
understand who you're talking to
understand what they value are they
willing to actually pay for that value
and then from that you can start to
determine what makes you unique what
makes you different from your purpose so
what is the purpose what is your value
what makes you different what makes
unique and then and then deliver against
that brand promise right the biggest
thing that people do is they start
running and started putting stuff out
there without ever defining all of those
things who you're speaking to the value
you bring what your purpose is what you
want to put out there either one they
don't they don't ever say it two or two
they say it but they don't ever live it
or three ultimately they don't deliver
on that brand promise and you can look
at the biggest brains in the world who
are you are kind of failing it's because
they're not delivering on the brand
promise that they give through the
marketing so I'd say figure all that
stuff out first and that can take
anywhere from two hours to two months
two years but figure it all out and then
the stuff to me seems tactical it seems
like you know it seems like doing
leadership things like starting a
newsletter and and you know Evan always
says lean into what you're best at lean
into what you know don't try to do stuff
that everyone does but lead into the
stuff that you're the best at so I could
say you know speaking to it but you know
networking but you know depending on on
what your strength is an eidetic
apologize i can't recall what you said
that you could to be a speaker but but
you know writing meeting with people
having coffee networking having a strong
social presence putting out videos
hosting a podcast and his endless
numbers of tactical things you've been
doing but it just comes down to you too
putting out who you are and then living
that and delivering for me this is a
pretty simple one if I'm a motivational
speaker and I want to get traction an
audience and more gigs I would go all in
on YouTube you mean are you good at
being a speaker you are then make a ton
of videos that move people and you'll
build an audience and get deals I mean
all the deals that I get to speak I mean
i'm flying to madrid in a week two weeks
ago remember um to talk to librarians
about using social media had a calm
through my youtube channel right and so
the look the the caveat there is that
you have to be good brand like yourself
has to be good but it's in any business
you have to be good at what you do if
you want to grow so i would just go all
in on making youtube videos consistently
respond your audience and people to come
that's our marketing strategy pick up a
ton of noise okay Angelo how can I start
a business without a degree
that's a great question I don't have a
degree I know Evan you went to
university I know that your plan was to
get big master plan in terms of finance
and stuff that you wanted to do in your
life took his switch I didn't go to a
formal college I didn't go to university
I went to a technical college and that's
part of what i was saying earlier about
who are you to do this you know people
say who are you to tell me how to do a
business I went to film school so iron
to school to become an editor to become
a producer and then I found myself
working with corporate people I've got
myself at a franchise and I found myself
starting my business dealing with
marketer the communicator and you know
what a few years ago I was like you know
what I don't have an undergrad degree I
don't have an MBA I have no formal
marketing training and and yet I know
that that when I offer strategy it's
much stronger than others and I know
that when our team does creative it's
it's really strong I know that what
we're delivering is best in class for
for what people are investing for other
things so how do I know that how do I
know that today it's like it's because
earlier on I kind of learned what my
strengths were and I played too many
trains I hired people who balanced out
against my weaknesses so that way as a
team we're doing amazing work and it
bothers me that I don't have a degree
but every time that I think about it I
realized that you know for Evan will say
like it doesn't matter people people do
not care about about the degree they
care about maybe what you can use the
degree for but you can get there without
that you can get there from learning as
when people ask me if they were home
school like I went to film school for
1314 years ago I don't know if I both
from school in today's world because you
can take that money you can take that
time you can invest in yourself and by
small equipment you can learn off of
youtube you can do everything you need
to do to learn and practice and make
mistakes and what have you on your own
so why do you need a formal institution
for that if you want to go in and become
a dentist or doctor you have to go to
school if you want to come on lawyer you
have to go to school there's no way
around that but if you want to be an
entrepreneur if you want to change the
world if you
if you want to do something big you can
you can hire people with that stuff you
know a side note i was interviewing
someone who start to a female
entrepreneur who's in our like 60s or
70s who started a makeup company called
leaves Walt yet and and she was a
television personality and she runs one
of Canada's and maybe even the world's
largest independent makeup companies and
it's because in the 60s she realized
that women didn't know how to apply
makeup and she was a personality and
then she learned that she could hire
scientists she could hire chemist she
could hire all the people with the
technical background and she just had to
be the face of the company she just had
to had to had to sell and define who
they were and leave the company and
enter in on everything but she could
hire the people with the skills needed a
degree except in cold for that so long
answer don't let it hold you back I love
it quick shout-out to time our weeks for
joining she was the one who got us here
together today which he said we need
mark in the car she said she wrote in
the comments mark in the car and I could
I called him work on the car at the
start episode she got us together and
insisted that we do something so then we
filmed an entire day of shoes that's
going to come up with the next week on
me to China because of you and I were
here I'm talking about on Monday
afternoon because through our podcast
she responded to this through this
call-out we did so she gets half an hour
wow you good idea so the point is I'm
suggest a question of Education I mean
as Mark said there are some roles that
you need to have an education in to be a
lawyer you know good luck being a lawyer
you don't have a lot of green but for
the most part you don't need it it's a
mindset thing one thing that you said
like you said that it bothered you that
you can have the grief I think a lot of
people have that stigma attached to the
human I don't have a degree and
therefore I can't be successful at this
and it's really just a mind game as soon
as you let go of that you'll be fine you
know like it's really just about the
value you can provide people and the
formal education system has very little
to do with the value that you can
provide a customer so just focus on your
customers and
but I said it earlier you right it's
that question that runs in my mind and
probably runs in your mind who are you
to do X so am I to change the world Who
am I to be able to give people advice
degree where my to lead a business or
people are older than and I'm hiring
people older than me Who am I to say I
have experienced when I don't like
that's that's the thing that I'm always
battling and you can if you're growing
if you'd if you're growing if you're
pushing yourself you're going to battle
that forever right because if you have
the point we're just like yeah I got
this down then you're a bit comfortable
not pushing not growing I don't know
even if you have advice on how to get
over that but that's that's the thing
that you're always going to fight ural
to take you am I to do with it I think
it's a my solution is surround yourself
with greatness you know I come from a
family where you know middle class
family my parents are educated they
believed in me no they weren't
entrepreneurs you know my dad worked for
the government years and got his pension
taught me a lot of values and Who I am
but nobody to turn to for kind of
business advice and then I was you know
right with my dad the other day in the
car and we're talking about an email
that I sent to Stephen Kelly who's the
CEO of sage this government's a company
15,000 employees and I was being really
hard on him like saying that what
they're doing wasn't visionary enough
and they needed to change you team he
had wasn't great and you know like if he
wants to be a changing for entrepreneurs
needs to step up and like just you
you've been on the receiving end of some
of those emails like whether i'm sending
it to mark you know a friend of mine
that I've known for however many years
or Stephen Kelly a guy who is a you know
newer friend who runs an insanely large
company my dad asked well where did you
get the corner guts to like what I set
up a second kelly and for me it's you
know by doing the work that I do on my
youtube channel I'm surrounded by huge
thinkers every day right every single
day i'm watching videos and people who
have done amazing things from
entrepreneurs to musicians to actors to
politicians to innovators and inventors
amazing things until that's Mike's
purple and so with with total respect to
skip it Kelly it's like it doesn't I'm
not fazed by it right because I feel
like I'm hanging out with steve jobs and
Walt Disney every day
you
here can you see us are we back I'll be
back ten hit us up if we're back are we
back back we're back uh Korea what I was
saying I was on a roll there it's frozen
frozen frozen frozen uh what was I
talking about I was always on if we
press around yourself with awesome
people online so the people that you
deal with day-to-day are normal people
yeah I mean you get to get the values
from your parents but then you also get
the negative ones you know the things
that might hold you back that you know
they're acquires education such an
important thing wise have the degree
such an important thing to some people's
because their parents probably put that
on them like you know maybe they were
page these are they always wanted you to
go to university and you didn't so now
you're feeling because you didn't do
that right so you're you're carrying
their expectations of you on your back
where that's not cool like you gotta
break preview your own person and if you
studying greatness and study successes
from with that and you look at something
in symbols education a lot of these
people didn't go and get that education
it's not that education is wrong it's
just that maybe you don't need it you
know maybe because you didn't go and get
a debt university degree that doesn't
mean you can't go and achieve wildest
dreams and so you need to create a
better environment for yourself and
hopefully like these videos help and my
channel helped and marking the car helps
in the email that they send out helps is
the more you can surround yourself with
that the more that wisdom that kind of
leeches into you to your mind and helps
you break through the police every major
breakthrough a part of my business has
not been from a tactical strategy or the
tax of solution of applied has been from
me breaking out of my own head smashing
eliminating person believed and then
dominated I mean taking massive action
that's where it comes from good does
that feel like we got back on track
there that was good okay we got a
question from from Julian let's read it
up Julian Julian is a had Julian onyx
channel couple times runs a dance studio
at what point do you monetize blog
YouTube channel brand podcast so you
have a podcast you have a youtube
channel live a waking bona fides might
be a little different than but other
people do but what do you think what
point unit eyes
if you have so the way i would look at
it which may be a little bit cold and
calculated if you have an audience and
you have advertisers and marketers lined
up you want to advertise that audience
and it's big enough you my top of it and
if you don't have an audience built up
it's not big enough you don't have a
following if it's going to distract you
to spend time trying to onboard
advertisers and things like that you
don't now if it's just about Google you
know like it being YouTube it's about
what click on you know a sense with you
pre-rolls or with ads or things like
that to me that's just it's a really
small decision because I don't think it
impacts a audience audience experience
quite that much so for example on our
channel we we have a bit too turned on
and we don't generate really any revenue
from it that's fine we just we just do
it for the heck of it so to me it's
always going to come down to if you have
an audience but given nature of a given
size but you have advertisers lon don
lined up it's a really easy play that
pays for itself plus on go ahead and do
it but if it hurts the user experience
of the so brand experience or if you're
gonna distract yourself from your
greater role in life or your greater
business running the side business of
lining up advertisers I talked about
that the number of times on the channel
you know the business that I'm in is
kicking up as much noise as possible my
industry and then monetizing on that
noise and all of the best deals that I
form have been from people finding me as
opposed to me going out and trying to
sell and when I was earlier in my days
on the youtube channel i was in wildest
would be such a good fit for this brand
you know Microsoft should look with me
or America especially work with me and I
would reach out and tweet them and say
hey I've got this great YouTube channel
and I can never work that none of my
outreach and my outreach ever work and
then because I kept producing content
that people like them I challenge of
growing randomly people would just find
me other other brand managers different
companies and find me and want to do
some kind of deal together and so what I
would say is one I would start
monetizing from the beginning if I could
you know turn on your you too
I don't know why that would be the
people say well you need to have a
hundred subscribers if I find the
subscriber is like where did that magic
mart come from monetize right away if
you can get if the brand deals are
coming to you and asking you hate it I
want to do something with you and you
like the company and uses their stuff
and you feel good endorsing them them
then bring them on right away I think
the danger that mark brought up is that
you can spend your time getting
distracted by going after these
companies that takes your eye off the
ball of creating content for your blog
YouTube channel of potash and that's
where you need to watch out because if
you just keep creating amazing stuff and
people like it and they care about it
and they share it I promise you the
brand's will come to you and that's
putting a little you know faith and
trust in the process of the work out I'm
proof that it does and so if you have
opportunities to monetize right away
take them as long as you feel
comfortable with them you're okay
endorsing them if you don't have them
yet then just get back to work it's
never been easier to get brand clients
coming to you and it's only going to get
easier in the future so just keep on
producing awesome content and they will
find its good i was great okay you are
fantastic sir okay haha bid bid hand
write a long email basically he's in the
POW wants to know how do I start a
business in the fall the situation here
is really bad non Connecticut
environment entrepreneurs what advice
could happen so what do you think I just
pulled it Evan for me I think it's again
it's another excuse like yes the
economic conditions might not be as
great in the fall as they are here but
you know what it's a world economy if
you can sell sup to the US market and
then your pain and whatever the Paul
currency is to bring on a local team you
could you could you could live like a
king because the amount of money that
you need to be successful they are
compared to here you know I'm in Canada
it's a similar climate to the US my
standard of living is higher my just
expenses are higher than it would be for
someone in the Paul there's lots of
example people who have broken free and
it's never been easier to break free
with the internet so i would find a
business if it were me
I would try to put in business that i
could sell to an international audience
you know my channel I'm based here in
Canada but most of my audiences from
America which has the largest
advertising dollars and most of my
clients my sponsors are in America even
though we have a kind of worldwide
audience and you're watching from the
palace oh thank you but I would try to
find I won't try to find that kind of
market and stop stop saying I can't be
successful because I'm from the Paul and
said say how can it be successful and
the rules for success are the same
whether you're from the Powell or Canada
or Zimbabwe or whoever you know what I
was I was speaking with we did a project
with pretty pretty wildly successful
entrepreneur in the finance sector and
he's personally you know the last 30
years he's a billionaire concerned a lot
of money and he makes an effort he's a
makes an effort to always give back and
help out the country he's natively from
and it was interesting because it was
challenging his mindset as someone who's
now in Canada he's a billion in her
which to me is mind-blowing but you know
why what would you say to people who
aren't in that native countries what
would you say they need you know isn't
the same thing all the time I was kind
of challenging him on hits on his
mindset he said no what what's most
striking or not spoken about it's that
it's that most of us speak about self
who come from these countries you know
they don't look around that they don't
see opportunity you know they're not
taught opportunity it's not it's not
part of their upbringing it's not part
of the values it's not part of what the
parents are teaching them and so they
live their whole life without the
mindset of opportunity or making the
most of what you have to work with and
it's a mindset thing that's giving from
parent-child or from school system to
child or from wherever you live and so
the Evans point and you know we could
say well we're really fortunate live in
a certain climate you're really
fortunate that you have a channel like
Evans I'd say because the more that you
see yourself on his side on on the side
of those with opportunity rather than
sorry I don't mean to sound so boxy or
anything but but you know you're by
being on the channels what I'm saying is
you're one of us we're all the same
we're all people who want to do whatever
we can do it's not us against them it's
not you against those with me with with
opportunity or a D or all together
because we all got our struggles we all
got our battles but but ye are we can
all do it is what I'm saying have that
mindset surround yourself with stuff
like Evans channel and other things that
I'm an outsider saying this because you
can make it happen when you have that
ryan right mindset and when you just
believe that it will happen just believe
11 feeling the love I honestly wish
youtube was around more when I was
younger because I had to go to books and
I couldn't find the right books and I
want to famous onto prevails and the
only way to get it was some read like
insane long biography where I wanted
them quick hits um you know I'm jealous
of people who are starting their I want
to be 19 now so my business but I mean
they're still there's still a long
runway hold on i'm coloring to you I'm
35 I'm 36 in May so still tons of still
tons of runway but I mean it's never
been easier to start a business and
surround yourself with ideas and people
that can push you to be the best version
of yourself never been easier okay Kevin
I start my own clothing line I have a
few shirts and business cards but I
barely himani if you have advice from me
I heard his fantastic story by a guy
named Alex and I wish I knew his
admission member his last name Alex I
want to say mcclain I'll explain i think
from Nova Scotia where he started I
think it's called East Coast apparels
thank you google all of those things you
might find the right guy but in
university in an incubator he was
challenged in the business class to
start a business and so we thought that
I'll start a clothing line and he he did
like four t-shirts 40 sweating
sweatshirts with a logo on and they sold
that so that he's about money and he did
like 100 more and then they call them
and then he did he did another hundred
and another 100 he's selling them out of
his basement of his mom's place he had
no money wasn't making any money you
just putting it into it into it into it
and people were lined up around the
block
to try and buy these shirts and he's
like two or three years into his
business now he still operates extremely
lean he still does very few things but
if you read the right up on this guy his
story is is ridiculous and so I was at
an event where this guy was getting an
award Alex playing again I think his
name is and another person getting award
with someone who who's built Canada's
largest clothing lines most successful
retailers is on you know Canada's
version of shark tank you know has sold
his businesses to to Ralph Lauren and
he's just this fantastic guy in fashion
and they're standing on stage kind of
opposite each other and the guy with all
the experience with all of the money on
on on Dragon's Den which is Canada's
version shark tank was looking at this
young guy and saying that is the
business i wish i was running that is
the success that i wish i had early on
and it's just a guy who does uh you know
hoodies and he's got a cool logo and
he's from a place and he's his average
guy and he's taking all of the money and
putting back into the business and he's
building a global he's building a
fashion line through online through
mobile inventory i would say read his
story read other stories like him you
know model some masters there are people
today in really small markets making it
happen they're making it work and i'm
inspired by a story i think it's awesome
i think the mistake people make in the
fashion business is they have an innate
free t-shirt and so you go on your
intent you invest all the money that you
have into this one t-shirt and because
quantities are what they are and you
need to produce a thousand shirts to get
the right price break you going to buy
thousand you buy 500 shirts and then you
sell two of them and you've got 998
sitting there in your garage or your
basement of your parents house and then
you don't have the capital to go and do
it again and you make the wrong decision
your first design sucks you know and
it's going to suck probably that's part
of business like often your first
product isn't that great and so if you
go all in and you blow everything you've
got on that first product then I think
that's what most people do and then they
have not been successful where how I
would do it is I would look at a
spreadshirt
or a website that similars hugs them out
there where's print on demand and upload
10 different designs and see what takes
off and you don't make as much per shirt
you don't make nearly as much for sure
but you also don't have any cost zero
cost like you invested money the
business cards you don't need business
cards right you don't need to carry
inventory of your shirts put it up on
spreadshirt see what sells engage in
social media put your investor time your
energy your hustle but not your dollars
into it and then you start building up
naughty or any people look forward to
the mixture that you come up with and
then you can put people on a newsletter
list and then when you get a sense of
what people are buying and what's
working for you when you discover your
style then it may be worth okay make
some money coming we print spreadshirt
now I'm going to invest into putting up
my own line and by no fiber matures but
no looking to sell it's never been easy
like this was not possible ten years ago
I'm so that's how we do it you don't
need money you just need great designs
and hustle if you're in there you go
what's the fastest way to get to 25
thousand dollars this is a real question
that's a question with the fastest way
to get to 25 thousand dollars yeah it's
just real quick it's a nice man what is
the fastest way to get to 25 thousand
dollars it's right there touring holiday
well whatever you want so you want to
get a holiday but what's the fastest way
to get to the five dollars Roy robbed a
convenience store someone said no and
the fastest way to get to five thousand
dollars is I mean you you get a job and
save your money you ask family friends
for money you go to a bank and you put
collateral up against you sell your car
you sell all of your stuff you don't
really need any more you minimize your
life work I'm so confused by this
question it's like it's like the most
random question ever well okay so first
I want it's a common question that
people have and I get it like you're
struggling you're trying to make money
it's just this is sense of frustration I
think you'll get from from successful
entrepreneurs who you ask it to because
entrepreneur's don't go into business
just trying to make money they're trying
to have an impact and make a difference
and through that you make money
and so at the end of the day the
equation is making monies go fired and
drive the more value provide to a
customer the more money you're going to
make you want to want to make two to
five thousand dollars tomorrow go
provide two to five thousand dollars
worth of value to some point that's the
key can you do that right it's not just
about pay if I sell this on ebay from
something i bought a garage sale i can
make a quick thousand dollars right it's
providing real bad you do that you'll
have success and but you know sorry to
interrupt but i think i remember talking
this guy who was looking at cutting
expenses cutting expenses cutting
expense to trying and yeah you can cut
expenses to save money you can sell off
all your stuff to make money but i was
looking at what this guy was doing from
a life stop one of you he just wasn't
working hard enough you know like he
just wasn't putting enough hours wasn't
pretty enough time he was cooking up
sweat sometimes you just have to add
value but sometimes you have to work
hard we got we got Sonam sanam Colleen
income the subway what's up oh we lost
their lots of stuff i would actually
know it cuts out quickly I just in New
York Ramallah fine alright cool well
thank you for calling it next Haider
Haider hopeful my finger either my
passion is sort of software company I
would like to become a success
entrepreneur I've started working on my
drinks but I hate my college man should
I drop my college or completely studies
you need your college degree so someone
put my mom said this was visit my
mother's advice so maybe not all parents
the same way but GD do you need your
college degree to contribute to the
business able on run or are you wasting
time when you're wasting dollars are you
do meet by the people i say my mom said
that to me because when i was in high
school I was taking an optional year in
high school and I wanted to go to
college and I could got into the college
right away and I mom said why are you
finishing this optional your class
call it you get so why you know I got to
finish my here and it says what people
do and this and that choose a sublime
like just just leave high school go go
to college do what you want to do so if
you're in college is a very similar
experience for your college and that
college degree is going to contribute to
the next steps within your with in your
path then I would say get out need to
see it through but if it's not going to
contribute in any way thinking big
picture and not letting the fact that
you hate it play into it too much then
do what you gotta do and just get to let
start with it you know for me it might
kind of helps with the opposite you know
for me it's big decision with the hearts
balls bed you've got a clear aight about
it if you're going and going you know
it's all this is always going to tough
fun for me because because education you
can learn a lot and it's a fantastic
backup iron like an altar ship doesn't
look out for you educationally
supplement jobs they're deeply about so
not having to get you can hurt you but
it could also mean if you a lot or out
you don't have a back-up plan don't have
a parachute when i said in my business
and my life had no income and I quit my
job and my daughter's three months old I
had no other option I had to succeed I
think entrepreneurs too often jump into
entrepreneurship within the back their
mind thinking of this record that yeah I
mean I don't want to tell anybody drop
out of college but for me any big
decision in life you make my heart not
your head and then you figure it out so
you're doing something general that you
hate every single day then maybe maybe
it's going to a different college
different degree change that up or
dropping out or taking a semester off
and then prevent you coming back to it
but all those positions are as well as
independent just don't you because it's
the easy way out by the family you know
I changed my degree in high school I was
going to become an architect I wanted an
architect and I did this film thing and
I was like hey Phil it seems like a lot
more fun but really I think it just
seemed easier to me and you know I still
I still sometimes we're going on I'll be
[ __ ] architect and you and all that
other stuff today I did you do it
don't know because it seems like it
easier than today that's what's messing
with you here this will insane long
passage here oh wow the bottom line here
get some Thomas was writing to say he
loves me channel he's trying to develop
them self awareness and reading people's
books and was like in that period is
digest and everything when he's saying
that you find a lot of people the five
meters saintly Robin brendon burchard
are doing what he considered scamming
and pollution techniques you an MLM
impaired and schemed and you want some
of interest and what good bites will
have to learn from so once I'm not good
scam I think he wants to learn to
develop but then he watches on to
somebody and then buy something as a
scam three kills of this game and how to
avoid that YouTube has so many to so
many free resources that you can learn
from I think there's a new there is
still a tremendous amount of value in
books that are being written hold on
commerce on my back you listen to books
and yeah you're investing in the book or
investing in a membership but other than
that your time and you can take the
information you want to you the
information you don't want anyone who
has a wall anyone who says you know you
know five for me my secrets to
mentorship a success or look at how rich
I got by doing these business trips and
for the most part all information is
outfit all information is bring you a
cycle if you know your most innovative
new things are still little bits and
pieces of other stuff that's out there
so if you look passion for it it's out
there all the information is out there
everything need is that there and no one
is going to make it easier for you
especially if you have a passion for
learning your passions avoidance
resources I'm gone too expensive events
like I've gone to think that my teacher
expensive opaque five six seven hundred
dollars to attend an event for a day to
meet its expensive and I've gone to free
events and you know what other than the
light show in the AUV I'm not seeing
much of a difference some of the best
well notes because I'm paying to see I
want to walk out of and the other one
the people are doing it for three and a
little local grassroots type event or
something money too I'm like heck yeah
this guy's breach it you're doing
amazing work because they're there
forget
they're different motivations so just
the best thing to do is just not get
sucked into it yeah for me I think it's
helpful to find some people that need to
look up to that you respect their
opinions on and you value them as as
human beings so maybe that's my chat
later that's mark in the car maybe
that's something else if you watch and
as long as you feel like you're learning
and growing then continue to digest it
and consume it there's been some
personal experience you know I've paid
for books but I haven't paid to go to a
seminar I haven't paid for anybody's
audio program or anything bigger the
only time that I did was with my agent I
paid to get media training from my
agency that was kind of part of the deal
and I almost didn't and the reason why I
did was because I felt like I would
regret it if I didn't dog that was
basically it you know I felt like if I
didn't sign with these guys I might
regret it and I hate living with regret
I could live with losing thousands of
dollars but not wondering and now that
actually worked out and it's been great
the only thing I would probably pay for
now I would be taking my kind of
speaking to the next level you know like
if Les Brown was coming to Toronto and
one thing someone I went to Pocono tidal
clunky for that I a huge believer in
mentorship and lunches pay for the lunch
but not the time with the person might
invite people out for coffee you can
connect send them maybe a gift or
whatever you like if you're desperate to
spend money on things okay and you're
like almost cash burning a hole with on
it doesn't spend money investing in this
then you know lunch lunches or evening
thinking logically for things like that
I think for the most part to Mark's
point is true and that the information
is out there I think the challenge at
the start is meaning to find it you look
at my channel most information of the
top ten interviews that I profile you
can find David eyes elsewhere on YouTube
why do you come to my channel to watch
because we've done the work watching 10
hours of video convention at the 20
minutes of the best stop and so when
you're a startup and you don't have a
lot of money you don't you don't go to
your time as much you have
more time than money you can go out and
research all these people and getting to
each you need is just inefficient
because you can't afford to go and buy
it where a lot of times the buying of it
speeds up the learning and you get it
faster but you know so you're saying
that you wouldn't really pay for any
seminar like I visited i went to a TEDx
conference on intended talks or all
three there are pretty everybody release
everything I I still think that what i
paid for the Ten Conference of the day
two hundred fifty dollars which again to
me seems like a lot of money to pay for
confidence that's an experience I would
do again I think I think it was worth it
i think being in that group of people
can access to like-minded even though i
can get it for free so again anyone who
generates all of their revenue on pain
or having even by secrets i would you or
your scheduler name or coach business
coach or if you want to get your life
coach anything like that we're working
one-on-one then I'd say it's more than
us I don't think test the waters you
mentioned 20 hours and brendon burchard
and others most people will have this
funnel where there's a lot of free
content and then the next step is a
seven dollar for you know by the book at
seven though it's not a big investment
you can value was it helpful for you the
next step might be mid $25 on your
girlfriend right like if you got the
book by that be able to jump into a
two-thousand-dollar someone are men feel
you've ever thought right each step
along the way we see if anything till I
got out of this person to shady or about
I'm not good value more believe and you
go find someone else if you click up to
alright are we doing crunching down
let's do it we got a couple more Bruce
how can find sponsors to my radio
station on the moment you I don't this
online radio or its local radio or what
but I mean my standing is that also most
you know if you died if you're like a
program director most of these kinds
have been a department most of these
companies have been existing audience
are geographic area which means
look at someone we handle sales well
like any tech media placement type sales
if this is an online channel if you mean
like you know how do I find people just
come on I feel like to address this an
earlier question everything we said
about blog I think we said about the
youtube channel or any other kind of
medium I think still applies yeah for me
i'm not the sales guy on the marketer so
i would forward me out just focus on the
content you know instead of trying to
sell something that's just okay maybe
something amazing that then sells itself
that's where I probably focus on the
product but everybody's buzzing about
your radio station what just happened on
and then guess you have in the quality
no radio that you're playing and
everything you just have the hottest
station the navitars will come because
they want to be where the attention is
doesn't work for everybody you know good
sales people be so mediocre stuff but my
way is is to just focus on the product
and market market market and you're
still stuck on what to do your small
business you still have the resources
look at what movie here just cuz you're
in a mobile communications channel if
you are an existing radium doesn't mean
that you can't lever to be a real ways
of applying sponsorship of sales to
content you to bring it I make pemmican
on the minyan hemming young I don't know
where some of this mail but simply let
me take the trends value your attitude
people's lives anytime I want your
content to feel so inspired other
question I would like to build and I
would like to learn how to set the
website for ecommerce but I don't have
them skills and how to create a website
if you want Destin summiteers rhetorical
to working more in class and masta how
to proceed commerce website retention
feel like their providers to this so I
mean I haven't done it personally but I
feel like Shopify is some one of the
work place that exists to help people
who have no coding experience set up
online these online marketing stores and
it collects into facebook its again I
can't speak to the product but I think
that's the whole premise the whole
premise is to help people have no
experience sell stuff online so i look
at Shopify I think Squarespace is
another provider who has
resource estimate check that into
eighteen dollars from unless some
commerce capabilities so you know google
it there are tons and tons of the
Affordable players out there to help
people like you to me with very little
coding type experience setup make it
easy to pay a monthly fee yeah for me I
think it's important to focus on what
you're really great at it can be one of
the best in the world that and so I do a
self-audit find out do I want to learn
how to program it's not something that
your passion though and we want to be
great at and it's not then don't worry
about learning it you know go to jump if
I start up start with a Facebook page
right just start doing whatever the
easiest thing is to get it up so that
you can focus on what you're really
great at an angle and just dominoed out
here if you want to sell if you're great
in front of the customer and that's
where you focusing the time you need a
website to get started I would not have
somebody who wants to be in sales
focused on coding and learning putter
you're never going to be great at it and
you can spend your time Amedeo Craig
something instead of harnessing your
needing to be great at something else I
would also look at the base camp model
they have a book called rework but I
mean the basic physical base camp is is
they are colors at our program which
company but they're just really trying
to like like seventy percent of book
even please everyone you're coming into
an online business you have a lot of
experience in it yes you can find people
who say they're going to go the most
custom most amazing thing but just get
started to Evans plant that just get
started and figure out how to please
like 60 or 70 people and and not worry
about catching everything in between
everything perfect from a usability
point of view of complexity point of
view or from us you know if they click
this does it does it offer to an
algorithm additional options and all
this stuff you know you can't look at
amazon to put it over eight there I want
to start there just get started lavanya
right hand from YouTube Congrats us
you're being followed by Barack Obama on
Twitter what if we want to make
changes really want to do the things
that would be Muslims analyze that we
are comfortable satisfied okay enough
current situation you never to make
changes so if you're if you're
comfortable you're not willing to get
uncomfortable obviously what you want to
do in your life isn't important enough
to push you enjoy being comfortable and
most people are stories that means so
for me I mean it comes back to the
earlier answer talking about environment
right like if there's nobody in your
environment if everybody around you're
saying why look at the great job you've
done and nobody's pushing you then it's
gonna keep on doing what you're doing
where if you feel like somebody's
pushing you to be better and that what
you've done is good but believes in your
talents to be able to do much more than
either try to reach out and do more and
it can be hard to find that person and
the way I do it again if I look for is
watching those videos of hearing
entrepreneurs I see yeah I was watching
one to be on mas we just did a feel on
my stuff and big ideas and this guy is
talking about colonizing Mars because we
want a back-up plan in case we screw up
the earth you know and here i am
thinking like a yacht me i want to build
toronto to be an entrepreneur hello but
i want things that have to go to
California to sort of business we can do
it here I'm thinking that's a big
thinking like putting my city on the map
and here's Elon Musk thinking about a
back-up plan for the planet you know
it's like just it's awesome but but you
know I don't have people who I talked to
in my network who you think on that kind
of scale so i try to surround myself
with people as much as I can online and
from videos who are doing bigger things
make me realize that ya ever done is
very I'm super grateful for it and
appreciative and humbled but also I
should be doing more like if you have a
green on sending a responsibility to do
more and those are the people who push
me to be better and better and better so
again you want to do great things in
your environment that helps you do
everything so I've been looking at
changing up your environment from the
people you hang out with to the videos
you watch from the books at you
things that force you to get
uncomfortable otherwise you'll just stay
doing what you're doing and then we've
got a question from to the top how do
you guys see lab being used six of 12
months and now and how do you think it
will affect how you can you get with
your audiences I don't know because this
is my first time on blab so it is what
do you think of all this is your first
day and what do you think about what
you're going to use it you're right so I
think that whether it's lab of specific
or it's a different medium like most of
the new interact mutants are coming out
there I think it's it's just changing
video from the communications to a
shared experience I mean that's a great
thing so whether you again let's let's
not just look at this one specific
platform if we look at all new ways of
communicating through video through
interaction is a new podcast app called
main career that came out last week or
people will upload the beginning of a
podcast and then everyone has the
opportunity comment in audio on that
podcast so it's a living breathing thing
I think the future whether it's six
months or 12 months a few years down the
line is a fully immersive interactive
world for all areas and you've seen this
in publishing and publication and books
where ebooks kind of you know a little
icon or something where while the reader
is reading they have the opportunity to
jump out the additional content or
Davina that's I've heard or the ability
to you know what the conduct of the word
or comment is is made they can link out
to learn but the district about if it's
about a total amounts of experience in
immersive world and really exciting to
me and that should be exciting to all
content producers because now we're not
being just tied to specific mutations
channel is medium but we're now creating
an ecosystem or environment of human
spontaneous or anything and then what's
most interesting to me is how people
have these things so how you you know
you start with something like like lab
or the periscope which is a super offic
a super
unpolished environment and how you try
to hack into the system polished
elements for choose your own adventure
for for a real time improv storytelling
or for getting real-time feedback on
things I'm you know I'm never really
interested in the initial concept or the
initial on my form line was interested
in what the beeping its incurred to do
what happened I think they'll be I think
this year will be a lot of a trend
towards one video and to live videos
it's not just watching the polish stop
but having direct access I think it'll
be a little bit more raw we're doing
this right now you guys can ask us
questions and are interacting in terms
of the platforms out there I like blab
the best because of the way that you can
communicate and build any beach it with
the people so it right now Tamara is
giving us cross so you can click on it
see her face right so it's like they're
come some more let's get to a thousand
come on a thousand a thousand she's
gonna do it we're gonna get there you go
that's cool people can cheer on so there
we have a guest some people could cheer
that person on as well I like diving it
tears we're gonna head that's hot right
like you can't do that after platforms
so that's cool now when a question comes
up like this into the top I can pull it
up to the side it's easier to
differentiate between the questions and
just a chat a lot of modern Greek chat
that's been happening filters talk but
here I can pull this up on the side with
lamb you can also help people call in
like we had that person try to call in
from the New York subway and then got
disconnected but that's cool right like
other people can call in and ask
questions and interact in a way that you
can't do the other platforms as much and
so I like those of you choose out a
built-in i'm using it right now and then
i download the beauty like uploading to
my youtube channel because that's where
my bigger audience is compared to do
this lab hopefully anos does something
similar like the google hangout platform
is not great compared the glass that's
why i'm doing stuff here on blood but
keep in mind google google hangouts was
to compete against skype so you know we
convened these informations of new
technology building on new technology
building technology but not the
broadcasting
the process the first google hangouts
yes but now the YouTube hang us for your
broadcast is your audience is just like
this where people can be interact with
your audience and you just have a live
chat down the side but you can't doesn't
have one of the features that I like
here where you can really like another
question there that are that are crops
we have a thousand ten I people can call
in to the show I think it's just a lot
more features and isn't getting more
developments like whether black becomes
Dilton winner who knows maybe two
discovers hey these guys are beating us
with engagement tools so we're going to
buy blab we're going to you know
incorporate some of us reduce into our
system as well so as a lot of employers
between periscope alive and Google
Hangouts mere kaan your job muskrat
meerkat something I like this the best
right now you know as things are
happening so quickly that something else
may change and maybe some new killer
future that I want to go back to youtube
I want to go jump on periscope who knows
but for now one I think the concept is
here to stay i think the idea of doing
live video will people can interact and
ask questions is going to be a super hot
trend this year that's not going
anywhere which company ends up being the
one that had execute I don't know it
doesn't matter them you'll see me there
and hopefully I'll see you there too
anyway thank you guys ah times the point
on the chat you can expect more mark on
the channel coming up in the next week
or people want to check in mammoth we
follow mark in the car but his real name
is Mark bigger from Phantom Mediacom
will link it up below we show the
questions we show the love it seemed to
believe I was he seeing guys everything
Jeff